connaître le positionnement de son corps
par rapport au ballon travail sur la
technique conduite de balle match ou
encore ateliers tir tel était le
programme de la journée découverte de la
section féminine du magny football club
on a envie de relancer le football
féminin sur manille on est convaincu du
potentiel de jeu ce qui peut y avoir sur
la commune et les communes avoisinantes
cette année on se donne d'autres
challenges de remonter une section pour
la saison prochaine aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on fait c'est pas pour se garder se
dire qu'on aura trois quatre joueuses
dont on espère vraiment créer une
section féminine avec une ou deux
équipes dans différentes catégories
aujourd'hui la pratique féminine est en
pleine expansion en quatre ans le nombre
de licenciés a doublé dans les yvelines
mais le football reste catalogué pour
beaucoup comme un sport dit masculin au
grand désespoir des futures joueuses de
magny les hameaux
c'était intéressant il ya on n'a pas du
football féminin ici et bah parce que le
football féminin s'est pas à jouer
partout et c'est voir se développer
pas pour qu'on proposait déjà plus les
garçons que les filles cdu comme ça ça
peut être sexiste
merci avec cette journée découverte en
dépassant les stéréotypes des passion
pour le football sont nés là-bas c'est
jouer avec elle les autres et apprendre
à jouer au foot
j'aime bien faire des passes et est trop
gros avis aux amatrices la prochaine
session découverte du football féminin
du club de manille se déroulera le 2
juin au stade de la pointe de chemin
cours à 16 heures